it's nearly ten o'clock when many hotel
guests will be thinking of heading to
bed but the music concert is just about
to start we've been doing this for 20
years we've been playing music I think
Gordon's gonna like
[Music]
[Music]
I don't do drugs
so never thought I'd see a dancing
mushroom but I was wrong it's like the
Summer of Love these people are weird
but they sure are friendly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's insane how guests are trying to
check in over this racket if I had
arrived to this I would have gotten on
the first plane back home I don't think
I'll be able to relax here I can't
really escape the sound and the longer
the music goes on the more guests
complain
[Music]
you know what it's
tonight okay we're gonna make you happy
no matter what okay
with Joanna giving away rooms for free
the lodge is losing money pushing this
hotel further into debt sorry to say I'm
sorry you mind
listen got some issues downstairs and
found some pretty horrific stuff I know
you're pretty for bed I'm sorry I
honestly didn't think I'm gonna put
anyone in here today
so that's mold underneath that it's
disgusting and I did a bacteria test
I've been doing them all day on my
shower curtain was mold [ __ ] we just
give me two minutes okay
[Music]
and I'd be really Frank I'm gonna try
stay so calm but if I smell but yes that
you start going into denial I'm gonna
let rip again I studied your
reservations
last November December 49 rooms were
given out for free and on top of that
they ate they drank for nothing I'm not
even tipping and I'm just [ __ ] you
didn't tell me why I thought I needed to
have somebody here rather than having
two other guests in the hotel all by
themselves to have more energy why can
it worse
not only do your friends not leave tips
but when people do to the stuff you take
your share on nights that I work I did
take two that is disgusting why do you
think you are right to that I have tried
to work with my staff to teach them that
this is the way I want service dog so
bad I take a percentage of the tips
based on the amount of work that I do
and who does the books from those tapes
ari but if I'm doing their job and I
can't get it across to them to the owner
you know the head busboy you know the
barman you're the [ __ ] owner what I
was saying wasn't getting through so the
psychology was that if I started to take
tips they would maybe pay attention to
that it's insane and the worst
management model I've ever heard in my
entire life do you honestly need a 70
year old lady's tips
so 15 20 grands worth of complimentary
rooms in the food in a two-month period
I'm just make sense I have to tell you
that the reason I did that was because I
thought that they would at least tip my
staff but they didn't tip your staff
sorry to piss on your bum fire well then
I won't call my friends and I will tell
them look what happened we haven't got
the [ __ ] balls to call your friends
and ask them to leave a tip yes I do
call them then and ask them I thought at
least at a generosity you would have
left a couple hundred dollars tip for
the team Dana its Robert you stayed here
recently and I was under the impression
that you and Greg left a tip did you
leave a tip no no but you said you were
going to send additional tip I think my
time to come here that was one of the
things that I was hoping you had done I
left the money with you
wait a minute there's others to call -
Gordon OH - Gordon has left
he thinks I'm stealing my staff's tips
unbelievable
[Music]
hey ray it's Robert did you tip the
staff because they're telling people
that they haven't been tipped I left the
money with you oh so I need to do that I
have somehow lost that [ __ ] in here
so you've done nothing since you came in
here but talk about me behind my back
try to set me up to fail every [ __ ]
day why do I want to make you look I
don't know I wish the hell I didn't know
but I've got several people we can line
up and we'll tell them exactly what you
imagine we will only thing you'll say
the party words not to me is I hope he
hangs himself or what it's about as
horrible as when somebody hires all new
people Intel decency every one of them
that she's a [ __ ] to work for you can't
work her either but hang in there
because it's six months I'll be running
this place and she'll be gone I mean
literally right on the box right out of
the box
there you go goes back to yeah because
that's when I found out what an
untrustworthy backstabbing son of a
[ __ ] you are I gotta worry about my
back continuously with you what's this
major miracle man that was supposed to
come in here and double and triple this
business when there's been no change
whatsoever none director me well you
wanted to hire new people which he did
so each and every one of them that they
shouldn't work for me go on site is that
true
there was the impression given that Cali
would no longer be here whatever place
why were you suggesting that she's not
going to be here after Sierra starts I
don't recall it everybody does the
general manager badmouth the owner
behind her back yes
cause she doesn't trust if you can about
mouthwashes about if you were the owner
what would you do I would fire that
person that bad now for me
you're fired